hey
oh ok again a trail
the key result of it hey welcome to the
kira soltanovich show and i am your host
kira soltanovich and today we're doing a
fun new thing that I've tried now
several times call in to our comics
we're gonna be calling a rain prior yes
that's right that rain prior a funny
comic in her own right a mom she's a
play with what is she like a scientist
also now to oh my god our conversation
was incredible and yes of course we do
talk about her father and we touch upon
at those I didn't want to make the whole
conversation about you know her father
being Richard Pryor of course that's
important it's part of her life and it's
who she is but she is so much more than
that she's fascinating I I honestly
could have talked to her for hours and
hours and hours we just talked about
everything everything uh you know
vaginas of course that comes up a lot on
the podcast but you know I sciency stuff
her parents drugs I mean everything
everything and I was fascinating and I
really truly enjoyed my conversation
with the rain prior and I hope you do
too I'm great thank you so much for
being on the show thanks for asking oh
my gosh I've been looking forward to
this forever I actually sent you a text
a while ago because Kelly Carlin was
kind enough to give me your number and
when you replied I i started to almost
like cry inside like you were so sweet
you were like oh of course absolutely I
was like oh my god I was like sweating
and I mean I might have been pregnant at
the time so they're a lot of hormones
going on but I was just like this isn't
me this is going to be amazing and
you're in New York right um well today
I'm involved some more tomorrow
beginning oh yeah I'd go back and forth
oh very nice are you working in
Baltimore no I'm just muttering in
Baltimore ah that's where you do your
mothering so that's where you live now
it's a white well no I
this is how I put it this is where I am
right now it's not where I'm going to be
I'm going to be in New York City got it
okay but right now you have Lotus unit
Lotus wants to move to New York City and
that's your daughter I got it I love
that name I absolutely love that name
and and how old is she e 77 okay so I
have a five-year-old boy please tell me
hey they could get when they're older
they can do what I said they can date
well they're also taking date when
they're older I would love it um i was
gonna ask you at five did she go through
a thing where um here's what he's going
through right now it's the end of the
world everything is the end of the world
if there's like the last piece of
chicken and he ate it and there's no
more chicken or whatever it is it's the
end of the world and my husband I look
at each other like are you out of your
mind and we and we want to say that to
him we want to say right like sometimes
you just want to talk to your kids like
their your peers I've told him so many
times I go dude get it together and then
look at my husband I'm like what am i
doing he's five he's but he barely wipes
his own ass I'm asking way too much of
him but it just comes out that's how it
is that's how it does it change at seven
please tell me it does what happens at
seven at least well I have a little girl
so what happens at seven if you start to
get the chief stuffing and the eyes
rolling and you have to do everything in
your power not to want it not to want
knock her the [ __ ] out not anything I
already I already have the the eyes
rolling but you're saying she does that
with her teeth the second of the teeth
yeah oh my god she's like big night last
night she barked at me I don't need a
boat I really want a bone damage now
that you are my job clay
see what I believe lotus is an 80 year
old woman stuck and it's gotten your old
body well that could actually be I have
run across kids that I feel like oh wow
you've not only been here before you've
been here a hundred times before and
you're actually bored with this whole
human process yeah she was me that she
is but ok so I'm thinking of an example
I do it could you relate to your mom so
well I haven't I happen to be a single
mother so on thanksgiving i was invited
to my ex-husband mud dirt mother
stepmothers house for thanksgiving he
wasn't there oh and it's a big family
gathering and so um I would I didn't
want to go I'm like that's not really my
family I don't want to spend it with my
ex-husband family right and Lotus looked
at me and she got out of the card she
grabbed my hand she looks in my eye and
she says mommy this is your family too
oh yeah i just started ovulating and I
was like yeah are you kidding me I
thought little wisdom telling me to
basically calm down pull your [ __ ]
together just walk in with your head up
off you know when the heads when they
drop like a deepak chopra moment on you
like that oh yeah it makes you kind of
looked like it kind of shakes you out of
normal life and watch me so much it
makes me look at the universe and go
really cosmic joke on me thank you you
did it at second did you always white
kids was that like a thing for you
you're like okay I gotta I gotta have
kids I want to be a mom no that's you
know what it didn't hit me until I was
in my late 30 mm middle 30s like 35 all
of a sudden minutes that I heard went
and talked about that clock yeah yeah
sudden one day it turned on it turns on
literally and some died where I didn't
end up marrying was like
expecting me like I think and I need to
say it but you know it's one of those
hot heated moments and he's like you
know I want you to have my babies and
somehow the clock like just went around
in a circle Charles ha you know like the
sea parted bird the dust yeah I had
wanted yeah and then when you have a kid
then your clock turns into like the when
you want to snooze for the other one so
when you want to have a second one all
of a sudden you're like oh my alarms
going off again you're hitting snooze
for months and years and years well I
thought I think I'm older than you so my
and lately and I don't have vote I don't
I don't I'm not in a position right now
to have another child although I do
really want another child meaning that
i'm not steady with my current partner
right yet to be able to say i want
babies so but the clock started again oh
really right i'm in behind in my mid i'm
in my mid 40 so my eggs are screaming
because they're dying I feel like it's
okay if you don't get pregnant it ain't
gonna happen but you know in LA that's
like all you have to go to is see an
acupuncturist and do a liver cleanse and
you know there's some sort of you know
doctor that can massage your inner thigh
and make you very fertile like in Los
Angeles that's not really it's not over
for you in LA now other parts of the
country you know if you're again in
Baltimore they're like oh you're a
grandmother already in Baltimore it's
girdles you don't have a magic Ivan I'm
later right I I thought we were one and
done for sure I definitely thought and
you know when you're a comic and and I
don't know how you feel about this cuz I
know you don't do just comedy you do so
much more and you are you still
traveling and singing and all that are
you still yeah so that that feeling of
like all right well that's important too
after the first couple years you know
after my
first I was like alright so back on the
road you on the road again and then I
internet snooze button hit and I just
kept snoozing and snoozing and and now I
have another one have a five-month-old
baby I edge elation well thank your type
you're just tired on [ __ ] I'm very uh
I'm not just tired it's like this level
of exhaustion that makes you a little
bit numb makes you like a little bit
like I'm just gonna like I've never done
any any hardcore drugs ever ever but I
will wake up leather and neither of you
but I will wake up like I am withdrawing
from heroin like I'll just wake up in
the middle of a night I'm shaking and
I'm sweating and I'm like what's
happening to me and I'm just like
scratching and I just it's because I
just want you know rest and sleep and my
own Fox in my hair and your hormones are
yelling at you go how did you do this to
us again again that's ever so do you
take your seven-year-old because she's
now old enough can you take her like on
the road with you do take her to gigs I
do not you don't know I don't because I
don't kind of water in that scene to be
office really hurt take her with me is
when I was doing my show in New York
Agarkar there cuz it's tough for her to
do the one-woman show tonight and huh
but what was the show New York the one
about um fried chicken lot bet that was
it right right right hey I don't want to
take on the road when I'm doing stand up
with a bunch of drunk guy you know what
I mean yeah yeah that I was depressed
did Jenna wondered if you don't want to
see your head oh you don't want her to
see you depressed I know I don't want
her to see that badge me been drunk men
depressed you know talk about like your
show when I like to toot you know I want
her to hear that yeah I know I
understand i've only taken my kids
technically on the road when it's been
you know like San Francisco I grew
up that way there there my family's
there or like if my husband's with me
but I might have to take one of them
with me to Vegas in a couple months and
I'm right really I'm really bummed out
about that well for one reason i can't
sleep in that means and i get vacation
out of it but i am I don't know I always
kind of go back and forth my five year
old loves to hang out in green rooms he
is fascinated by it I don't think it's a
great place for him to hang out but I
have taken him a couple times to just
comedy clubs here in LA and he's
constantly asking me when he can go hang
out specifically in the green room I
don't know what it is about that setting
but he he's asked me you have a manager
you burst manager hahaha totally worth
the manager oh I hope I hope it's just a
manager because he's actually gone on
stage there's like a show that were kids
can go on stage and tell jokes and he
went on stage and it was nothing to him
he didn't think twice he wasn't nervous
he wasn't shy he charged up the stairs
went straight to the microphone took it
out of the stand it frightened me and he
was like he wasn't even he just turned
four at that time oh wow so he has it he
might have it I bet and I'm really
worried about that because I'm like what
or he's a manager it's for him to be on
the stage I don't know what it had I
mean yeah I hilarity well did you you
know you grew up with two obviously
comedy people and obviously your dad you
know the biggest name in common i ever
but your mom also was you know in the
business right yeah yeah i did set up
copper wash with a dancer for a while
yeah and she was a writer yes and came
from a common house family yeah yeah and
now she's scientist right now she's a
scientist tell me what she's doing right
now because it sounds amazing and I'm
into that kind of stuff like I meant
she's thighs off yes my mom right
astronomical
content for Cal Tech in different places
she's an astronomer I love that and she
runs a a hundred a hundred inch
telescope yes wow wow compensating for
something mom hmm Elroy yeah I crazy and
15 it all was she she was like a hippie
mom right she was like kind of like a
hippie Jew he was and then I don't know
what and then she wasn't crazy so I
don't know how that other than my mom
literally to the genius the woman's a
genius so is so what kind of pressures
that for you your mom's a you know
scientific genius your dad a comedy
genius what do you when it's almost like
where do you what do you do from that
how do you I can't imagine if my my
dad's a plumber right let's say I try to
install a toilet and then my dad's I
good you did pretty good job he's
Russian that's why I gave him that crazy
accent you know you do a cake but packed
alone that's pasiba but imagine if my
mom my dad is the best plumber in the
world I wouldn't even go near of toilet
I wouldn't even like I wouldn't even try
to begin to install a shower or is gonna
me like I wouldn't even I would stay
away and yet you were like all right
I'll jump into you know what I don't
because no one else around me did
something else like entertaining was
just that thing my dad and my mom both
said I came out of performance really
knew that's what I was going to do my
sister went to college and have a career
yeah sometimes I wish I I tried harder
in high school you know maybe I know and
that's what's so fun so it's in me I
don't know anything else other than the
fact that i know i have that genius mark
like like just the other day i'm not
kidding you i'm looking at patents that
match that kind of being similar to
intervention i came up with really
nanotechnology
using electrodes in the body blah blah
blah yes but I was reading up on these
patents to see is there a way I can go
around them that won't sound similar to
the 10 the 5 that I just that were found
for me wait wait wait what are you doing
with nano what I just I got a google
haff what you said I have to look up
what you did what though so I came up
with this invention using nanotechnology
okay some people call it micro like
micro technology but it's nanotechnology
and so I came up with an invention using
nanotechnology in in in the body
nanotechnology in the body are these
like some sort of things that you attach
like like an EKG you would attach them
to your body it would it would it would
be attached internally along the spinal
cord and into on the frontal lobe
internally along the spinal cord like
octo like Doc Ock yeah yeah yeah so I
was I've been yes I'm having to read
their five patents that are similar and
I'm having to read through them and look
at all the technical language which some
of it I understand don't ask me why and
for how and then some of it I don't just
to see if there's a way to still do mine
and not have it be similar similar to
what has already been patented so I can
patent so what would people do with this
so the object of this is to help to help
actually to help people who have i would
say who have mobility problems than me
it's like you have legions because the
Milan was destroyed which is part of
what carries your nerve endings is
destroyed these actors artists almost
like artificial nerve endings I see
answer you can take down your nemesis
spider-man also right you can you can't
i'm thinking more like you know Ultron
yes so this is wild i don't i dined
never knew anything about this you know
I've I've always liked been a fan of
yours and kept track of what you've been
up to ever since you know I remember
seen you on head of the class but I'm
sure I'm not the only person that's been
fascinated by you um and but I've this
is the first I've heard of this this is
kind of crazy and very cool that's very
cool well I hope you find a loophole I
know right I think I will and so you can
way around you can do this and have time
to to perform and have time to be a mom
and all the other stuff that you're
doing yes i have found a way in my life
to literally balance at all I think I'm
superwoman but someone forgot to teach
me how to fly how do you look in latex
though that's what I need to know how do
you look in a cape well you know I think
if I leave a few more pounds I look
really hot girl you don't have to tell
me right now I lose the baby weight I
got I am in my pre-pregnancy pants but
unfortunately I have an empty and a CT
which is a muffin top and camel toe and
I'm okay with that because i am in these
jeans i am not wearing maternity pants
today and that is a huge high-five to
myself and I West deal with the
repercussions I killer plug oh it feels
amazing so something I ask people um you
know parents that are in the biz was
about their childhood and I can only
imagine yours um probably very unique
obviously and very different but I ask
people like okay so are you trying to
parent differently than how you were
raised you know for example I came from
a really loud aggressive family and
unfortunately I am loud and aggressive
with my kids I try not to be but you
know there was a lot of screaming and
yelling in Russian in broken English
right but you know I live in LA and I'm
um crunchy a little granola I'm a little
also a little bit of a hippie Jew and I
I try to talk about feelings and yeah
it's discuss let's draw a picture of
your feelings right now you know like
try to do all that stuff cuz I want it
to be different than how I was raised do
you that your goal as well oh yes I'm
you know I'm a much better parent than
my parents work because the world
doesn't you know my parents had me
during a time what it was like you know
you had children but then it's like you
always felt they stalked your career
yeah how are they were going to enter
feeder where it's like lotuses lotuses
whole thing is like how can i make my
career better so she doesn't suffer when
she gets older yes like you know what I
mean and so yeah do we talk about
facilities yes and and my daughter at
least with me is totally expressive and
honest and enlightened like I said
already you know she was eight year old
woman in a 7 year olds body yeah
brilliant I read her to be brilliant you
know I encouraged her to do her homework
I encouraged her to be better than then
cheated and I constantly tell her she
she great and wonderful and she's
capable you know and and when she messes
up there are moments with mommy yelled
really loud and Lotus turns each would
you sound like a lawyer it's a like she
has like some animals at her past life
with the dog and the lion right
hilarious laughs I guess [ __ ] that and
did you have that when you were a kid
like did you have that kind of
encouragement where your feelings her
did people listen to you oh not at all
00 up in the hole you know beefy not
hurt yes and what was your what was your
childhood like I know that's such a hard
question to answer and
what it was you know I'm okay so for me
the way I grew up it was normal right
wasn't going on there and have a dad
that was on the road and you go in and
you see the different women and the
different wide and then I have a mommy
with the total like gypsy and didn't
have didn't have lots of money that came
from an upper middle-class Jewish family
and so he lived like two separate worlds
I'd go to my dads and have the maids in
the blurb and we're shopping at fred
segal just because we can and I go to my
mom's house and it's like save a lot you
know so they had like dual custody so
you were back and forth a lot yeah and
you have a lot of sibling s did you grow
up with IE of them I are you close with
them still the older ones i am the two
older ones i'm closer the younger ones
are way younger than me they're still
like in there and their late 20 is now
really you know I mid 40 so it's a
different Jenner you know my jab right
have to be over what get done closer and
did you grow up with them or were you
guys kind of in sifrin in separate
places we're definitely all in separate
places except for about certain holidays
he would spend with dad and so then we
would all be together let's say at
Christmas we'd all take trips to Hawaii
to London to plan without and we get
together and then we go our separate
ways and we never talk and then now
we're at that place where we kind of all
live the three of us live on the east
coast so we had to talk more right I got
better as much but we still talk more
than we did when we were younger you
know and do you remember the time in
your life when you were younger I don't
know maybe it was like five six seven or
maybe younger than that when you
realized why is everybody all up in my
dad's business like who is he like why
is everybody looking at him to picture
look when i was at 4i met my dad and it
was at a big party and i was tons of
people around so i knew he I mean he has
his spinning I don't know what I need
but I knew he had this thing and I
thought it was normal for kids to have
limousine haha
no to have let the driver like em too I
know that were poor black people my dad
was rich right my mom was poor so I was
like white people are poor people God
got it going on right no no my dad's
like breaking down reality to me and I'm
like oh oh my mom was screwing the sub
could you posed to be on the other side
of it and then were you allowed to see
his comedy like were you allowed to go
to shows or what movies you were one
daddy frickin one really i think my
first i was jumping with someone i said
i think my first words were [ __ ]
which i'm sure sounded adorable coming
out of a small child's mouth I you know
cuz my five-year-old says the word purse
and it sounds like Puss and I just think
I'm like absolutely let's not let's not
correct that at all let's keep that
going as long as we can so five
daughters a prude is she my daughter the
food she will not curse and if I dutiful
mommy oh wow shed any idea was to ship
any idea what her lineage is that she
thought I could look down crust all the
time like I hope my child I'm telling
you she's an eight year old woman but
does she know about her grandfather she
said today in the part of me was driving
to school and she said my teacher
mentioned grandpa to the class and I
wouldn't he say he said hurt or grandpa
is a famous comedian named Richard Pryor
and she goes but my mom is famous
because she's raindrop I mean all of
that yeah that is awesome i love it yeah
so what was adorable this is this is a
random question um and I just just
watching Barack Obama's last State of
the Union I don't know if you had a
chance to watch it um you
I mean it was it was austere in' Aaron
our engineer by the way is here Aaron
you didn't watch it either what is
happening that's the youth that's the
problem with the year no I go to bed
with my child that's part of it ah yeah
see I have I have a problem I have a
sickness we're eight o'clock comes
around and I have mom Nisha which is I
forget that I'm a mom and I'm out at the
improv I was at the improv last night to
1130 and then all of a sudden it's like
it's like Cinderella like a clock
strikes and I'm like [ __ ] and I
run through the parking lot I lose a
shoe my car turns into a Datsun you know
whatever like I completely forget that
I'm a mom and again last night got home
way too late after two sets at the
improv and then my kid like you know 2
a.m. cuz she's hungry that's just ah
what am i doing but but I was just
thinking like um just because we're
talking you know you're you're half
white half black like that must I don't
know about you I cried when I voted for
Barack Obama I'm sure for someone like
yourself Oh what was that like what was
that [ __ ] like being a black
president right is that we can yes well
it was important it was important
because you're like what we can do
anything and you know okay so in my life
here I prep let's say I practice what
some people call law of attraction and
all that stuff right yes so for me it
was an affirmation that I can literally
be anything I want to be right and my
daughter knows no different and my
daughter doesn't my daughter doesn't see
what I saw growing up she's like but
when you talk about history she's like
yeah but mommy we have a black president
right isn't that great though it's so
[ __ ] awesome is my son racist tell me
this because as tall black man haha
probably right this tall black man
walked into his school to pick up his
kid and my son
goes mommy is that the president I know
right I don't think it's time jesus I
think it's he's aware that our president
is a tall black man right I don't think
that's racist now if he said is that guy
coming in and kidnapping my that kid
little been made I was right well he did
say is is that the president and he's is
he about to rob us he did say that part
I left that part out no yeah he's learn
about it funny because let me tell you
something more instant and I'd had to
correct her and I did but I was highly
embarrassed my face turned bright red
you know we will we were in one of those
convenience stores mm-hmm walking around
it and walked in a woman in full burqa
mm-hmm and a bell in a burka and notice
that mommy mommy it's Darth Vader okay
and I had a pod and I pulled her pull
her to the side and I said Lotus that is
a Muslim woman and she's wearing a burka
know how to explain the whole thing and
then she went ha oh and she started to
cry because she was embarrassed that she
hurt the woman's feel Oh see I would
have your better parent than I I would
have said no sweetheart that's Darth
Maul that's a different costume let's
see because I'm a socially conscious mom
yes I know [ __ ] Krauts ain't
appropriate thing I think you're right
when she sees a guy with the high-heeled
shoes and my daughter said why is a man
wearing the shoes and I said because he
can walk in them haha you know um this
is something interesting how do you deal
with this we have this one stretch where
we live all the set out of nowhere it
has turned into like a cardboard City
a lot of homeless people and my heart
just breaks and I bring extra food I
don't know if I'm doing this the right
way or not the right way but i will
bring extra food with me when i pick up
my kid and as we drive home I want him
wrong yes I want him to see me at the
red light I run I raw you know roll down
the window and I go hey would you like
some you know i'm literally doing like a
reverse Mexican I'm like would you like
some oranges like I'm giving oranges to
the homeless people like I and they're
like oh thank you so much come to the
window but I'm doing it I'm I'm
manipulating it I'm doing it no you know
what you are you're what everyone
Republican called the social well I am I
am a [ __ ] commie I come from
communist yeah I'm a Russian but I want
him to see me doing it like I'm not
doing it you know like an anonymous like
I'm gonna just anonymously and donate
money to charity so that nobody knows oh
I'm doing it like it's a tip jar and the
barista had just made my coffee and i'm
slowly putting my dollar in like i want
you to see me doing this like a Seinfeld
episode but I want my kid to to see me
giving food to people that need it or I
actually get once gave a bag of clothes
and this chick looked at me like are you
crazy and I go look would you like this
it's cold outside now I know it's la
cold so relax but you know it drops down
to almost 60 so I have like all these
old sweatshirts and I go you know would
you like some old sweatshirts and at
first she was like [ __ ] I want some you
know I want a sandwich and then she was
like oh you know what you're right it
does get cold at night so she grabbed
him and my son is and I'm doing it on
purpose so that he watches and ask
questions you know I don't want that but
it ok or my being like I starts
perfectly ok ok ok so I don't want to
seem like a goody two-shoes in front of
him like oh my mom is out trying to help
people again but I need him to see the
light will net help sometimes that's
great that he sees like okay we can do
that and he does ask questions look
weird if you look at it historically we
all used to live in tribal community so
you're doing the right thing anyway
you're doing what you're innately meant
to do and I just it's too much for me to
drive by them now and he asked questions
I mean every time he asked questions
every time they all act it's not gonna
stop it's not an affair they don't shut
up I don't shut up Kara I know I thought
our gaps and ask so many questions I
want to kick her in the vagina just like
she'll be like ow and there's quiet now
do you ever do you ever get into the
answers too in depth or do you just kind
of give like Oh sometimes people don't
have money for our house and then leave
it at that or do you like well because
the socio-economic system and because
they're set up to faith and are like do
you get into like you do no I get it
yeah because ok so both my parents
besides being their brilliant cells were
also social accident yeah I'm a social
activist so yeah I end up going into the
whole thing so she understands it you
know and and yeah well I try to do that
and then I watch my child's face change
and then he interrupts me and goes can I
get the new fire station Lego I like oh
okay you just have not listened to
anything I have said like zero okay but
what's up no he really had and he's
doing to you what you should do to him
which is shut up like he's done with
executives I got some way of shutting
you up to be like all right and that's
already I've heard it I get it yeah as
much as my little head can get now be
quiet mom so now now we have a girl
right I find myself already raising my
kids in it like in a sexist way but like
the opposite way so like when my son was
little I never said things to him like
you have a strong voice you know it
makes I assume he's a boy but like my
five month old she'll be she's already
like babbling you know already doing
like the loud like baby talk you know
and I'm like that's right you speak your
mind she's five and I'm wiping her
after you know I mean like after a
diaper change perfect right I find
myself treating her already so
differently you know like I don't know
how are you raising your child and be I
could I don't know the answer Justin
talking to you just you know these brief
moments but like like as a woman and
you're a comic and all these things that
you have been up against and you're you
know biracial I mean there's just so
much like do you tell like a little
brother on her on her dad's side or
lesbian yes yet oh absolutely right my
child is a liberal chocolate so do you
get our small doses or just later ah do
you give her small doses or just lay it
all out on the table for her you know
what we're all very open like we answer
her question but one of the what I call
one of her lesbian grandmother's used to
be a midwife she learnt Oct network
which and which educates young people
about sex and and you know and sex toys
and hello and protection and all that
stuff so my child is growing up smell
like it's funny she I remember one time
I like oh yeah I used to call her vagina
JJ she's like it's not a JJ mom it's a
vagina that's when she was 4 you see and
I have it I have a bit about that on
stage right now where I say let's not if
yes I say let's not give our our kids
euphemisms for their you know for their
business I don't call a business you
know like I do a bit about like my
friend calls her four-year-old you know
she's like we just call it a cookie or a
zim zam or a slip slap or a flip flu or
but remember that you know or and I go
please don't call it food no it's just a
cupcake or a Tootsie or at tysons
chicken dinner like why are we don't
call it food but she's right your kid is
right yes but that's what she called it
now oh Jesus well bedhead you get he
actually painted it up on me she's like
it's my between e
and I said I said but it's not at your
vagina cuz mom it's between my legs it's
a between e between I think she just
created a new product if you get to
modifying patents go find a patent on
between ease and then you guys need to
create a product like a kit like a kid
product called the between oh that is
genius Alette hilarious and she's when i
watch her rationale for it be pleasant
because I learned the between yeah I
don't know that when I read look I I
have to stop reading all some of the
nonsense and [ __ ] on the internet
when it comes to like kids and abuse and
all this sexual [ __ ] like there were
a couple things that happened since I
became apparent that paralyzed me with
fear you know one of them was the
Sandusky thing that happened a few years
back by I talked about in this podcast
before it has it has scared me more than
anything else in the world and I'm
talking more than Isis because I feel
like Isis is this thing that is is
happening in the world and by the way I
think there were some new attacks today
in Jakarta if i'm not mistaken yeah and
it's it's it's definitely real but i
feel like that send dusky that [ __ ]
that I feel like is possible you know
what I mean like that's in your own
backyard real and that and then like all
the Jared Jared Fogle from Subway all
that nonsense and just all this stuff
that that is around kids and abuse and
oh here's my thing about that carry and
this is just like this is like mother to
mother uh-huh Terrance apparent right
yeah I have taught loaded then she was a
kid 21 be open with her feelings open
about what happens what happens to her
if anything and where people who who
where do people should not touch
mm-hmm he doesn't want them to function
of the kid yeah my child is the most
honest on it I mean she's so honest
sometimes I think she has Asperger's
like she's that kind of 10 just like I
I'm so glad I've made I I raised her
enough to be comfortable that if someone
were to try anything my daughter would
say no right don't you don't do that
that's not okay and I think it's parents
we need to teach our kids that kind of
confident about who they are yeah and I
would be good offense to what you're
saying about don't give it don't give
our don't give our vaginas and penises
cute little late right because then they
tell an adult someone touched my cookie
and it's like all right we'll just get
another cookie you're like oh all right
and then you no problem not solved but
you know I am I my three I think he was
three at the time he was having like
stomach issues and you know all parents
we all we can talk about poop and stuff
and nobody cares but um poor erin our
engineer does not have kids so he's
gonna have to just sit through this
sorry sorry Aaron um but Aaron you poop
right I do all right so do you find
you're fine with it you can deal with
this everybody everybody poops hey um so
we had to take him to a way to take him
to a pediatric gastroenterology I yeah
pediatric GI and you know she was very
sweet very nice woman obviously has kids
and just a total sweetheart pro and he
was lying on the table and she said okay
sweetie I'm just gonna check your bottom
and then all of a sudden her tone
changed and she said you know no one
should touch your bottom unless it's
mommy daddy or a doctor when I broke
down crying I lost oh I could start
crying right now i could start i I'll
heal myself already
like when she said that I realized I've
never said those words to my kid before
right and he just he was so little and
he's just like can I have a firehouse
Lego like I'm sure his brain not even
listening but the fact that she said
that she changed her tone and she said
you know no one except for mommy daddy
and a doctor when mommy and daddy are
present actually she added that in a
doctor mommy and daddy are present and I
lost my [ __ ] and I just know like that
lump you feel in your throat and I was
just like oh my god I would kill I would
kill I would kill somebody like that's
the only time I ever feel like I yet
that makes me rageful and tons of
children makes me rageful period and to
know that it's now so much more
commonplace but when we were kids it was
not and especially especially your
father who was so public about like his
childhood made him who he was absolutely
but I think it what listen the reason it
doesn't seem less popular because they
didn't have the internet access right
right you know what I mean otherwise it
would have been all over the play they
were doing it forever they've been doing
it forever it's part of her if you go
back in our history they talk about
pedophilia it doesn't make it okay no
ever do you something I did not murder
in a new society now when we talk about
this stuff we actually put it on the
table and dissected now like you know
what this was f dot yeah and I oh I'm
not something like you to Catholic
school oh my husband went to Catholic
school for 12 years and his priest was
recently like a few years back his
school you know the head priest was in
the news um and there was like a big
payout and kids came forward and I was
like Michael are you sure cause a lot of
money involved yeah sure nobody touched
you he's like no no my god
Michael we have a mortgage are you sure
think better are you repressing
something and then one of his priests at
his school married one of the students
Wow yeah just [ __ ] up I mean I it's
huh it is it is one of those things
where sometimes you want to shine light
on it and then sometimes you're like you
know what I'd rather shine light on
positive things but then I feel like I'm
burying my head in the sand because you
look you and I talking about parenthood
right and the thing and the things
you're bringing up are awesome and I
wish everyone talked that way I wish we
talked that way with our partners you
know i wish i could sit down with a guy
and have a sexual conversation that
isn't about necessarily my arousal at
the moment nothin is about i want to
tell you how to eat me out properly okay
interesting we know like a buzz like a
BuzzFeed video right like I want to have
the sexual conversation everyone's
afraid to have because then it takes the
stigmatism off it takes the mystery out
of it it takes you don't I mean you can
like I'm one of those of one of those
that believe as soon as you put certain
drugs into the community nobody wants to
use of any more cuz it's not it's not a
secret uh-huh yeah the secret away is no
longer to dick if you talk about sex
nobody's gonna try to sneak off and try
to screw a kid right is that yes there
are crazy chemical imbalances and people
I get that part and it is a crazy
chemical imbalance in people but I think
we're so repressed as people right that
we create this stuff does that make
sense yeah well I don't even sound crazy
that's okay but I'm just saying no use
about this [ __ ] talking about drugs you
you said you don't do any you have never
done any I smoked pot right well yeah I
mean yeah absolutely look Scott I did
cocaine once really what called my dad
up told him about it because I couldn't
believe he would
ever put in touch that stuff my dad's
comment to me was are you sure you're a
prior rock [ __ ] oh [ __ ] how awesome is
that never did it again I was like
you're an idiot for doing this stuff so
isn't it interesting like my father's
father was an alcoholic died from
alcoholism my father does not drink just
dead like it sends you one of two ways
right you just you go hardcore like what
you know like how you were brought it
out do it or you just like [ __ ] it I
just don't is that something that you
feel because you saw it you saw things
firsthand yeah yeah and I be and I also
became a drug counselor really he kind
of back those like I'm gonna help people
and then I just didn't want to be around
people like that at all anyway so do you
want them do you think you need to have
some of like what do you think you need
to have to be a comic then because it's
like your father had everything he had a
crazy crazy childhood yes what is it
tell me every break something down to
you and I don't need to hurt hurt
anybody I don't you stand up anymore
well we are all devastated why not [ __ ]
because I'm not ah see yes I'm I'm happy
you're happy and that's exactly my point
I don't happen I don't think you can do
stand up if you're feeling great no I
never thought a happy stand up never I'm
here yes and I don't mean that in a bad
way I've never heard a happy panda I I
was on stage last night and I I felt bad
because I was kind of like joking around
about you know have a five month old
baby and I go look if I told you guys I
have a new baby and I love her and
everything's great and she's amazing I
can already tell she's a good person
people just be sitting there going okay
and and then I have to go but [ __ ]
babies babies those [ __ ] are
[ __ ] block in our lives I was like yeah
hey like that's all I can do is I know
it's so true so when did you have this
epiphany of like maybe I need to stop
doing stand-up because I feel really
great about my life it was it was it was
last year i did i did a good and what's
so funny that happened after i got i
went to texas i did shows and the first
time ever i got a standing ovation for
my stand-up ever oh and i just had
recorded my first ever stand up like
album i think and i realized i'm not i'm
not depressed enough or I'm not woeful
enough or I'm not whatever enough to
make people laugh about this kind of
stuff like it's not it's not it just is
in my world and I'm okay with that right
I'm like okay I'm different I can make
people laugh in different ways I can
joke about different things but to put
me on stage night after night in that
atmosphere it doesn't work for me like
that suppresses me and then I don't want
a joke about that I see I don't want to
joke about the guy after you know who
all the guys I walk up to you and
they're like oh you know whatever they
comment on your kicks your ass or
whatever your jokes you know and they're
all trying to sleep with you and two on
Richard Pryor's daughter which asks a
whole nother level to it and I'm like I
don't want it i faded a couple of
comments I can't even gate that I'm like
I don't even want you in my life like I
want my girlfriend to it funny of course
Karen you know but it's like I don't
want I don't want a getting accomplished
no that is a terrible idea I even told
my husband I go it's a terrible idea for
you to date a comic and he's like all
right well this is we were back when we
were dating I was like are you sure you
know he is he's a normal person I got
you sure that you want to get into this
that's why work that's why it worked
yeah he's knowable in your comment yeah
yeah and I was already working at it
established kind of okay i cain't a
normal guy what does he do not
entertainment whatsoever he's a lawyer
nice any chance he's a patent lawyer cuz
that would really come down on me right
now no I'd all right so before we wrap
up because I don't want to take up too
much time and we are we're learned oh my
gosh Oh focus up from school so oh ok ok
good so we'll wrap it up I want you to
give me one of your best i always i used
to ask people this more often but i want
to get back to it now I used to ask
people their best childhood memory and
their best parent Dan memory you know
just something that when you were a kid
just really sticks out and then
something when you became apparent that
you were like oh I get why people do
this I get parenting what something that
really sticks out for you I think those
would be a nice way to end about why I
how I grew up in me just like a
childhood memory of yours that really
like a great one that really stands out
to be honest and I think it's hilarious
to me what stands out for me is when I
thought my dad hadn't said Anne and I
was terrified I was care how old were
you have what I thought I think I was
six years six or seven I think 06 I ran
into my room and shut the door and hid
under the covers and my dad walked in
and he was pretty was like oh what's
going on and I might see what I saw here
Sarah tournament on my crying and he
goes brain that's what we call [ __ ] it
he goes and one day you'll be [ __ ]
two and you'll like it oh my god that is
insane who was he who was he [ __ ] was
he [ __ ] your mom or someone else and
he was okay using that language with you
and you were 600 and always I'm sure and
you probably have a special relationship
with the n-word as well
yes which is I don't say it don't say it
wow that is that is a great memory I
never did that until I was probably like
19 or 20 I walked in on my parents and
that's a whole different horror but yeah
I can imagine well I mean hey he was
right one day you were [ __ ] and you
liked it yeah so and and what what's
like give me like a great parenting
memory please don't tell me it's when
your daughter walked in on you [ __ ]
please i want able to handle it she
never ever seen that she's ever even
seen it no I mean masturbating yeah oh I
want to tell you though I won't tell you
this what did the great parenting story
well my daughter found my vibrator and
asked me mommy mommy how do you turn on
the purple microphone haha and what did
you say and I'm like one day when you're
older I'll [ __ ] you up nothing oh my
gosh Oh see that that's Wow see you need
to lock up guns and you need to lock up
dildos that's what I feel I feel like
you need to put the guns in a safe well
I cannot thank you enough rain for
coming on the podcast yes habibi you're
such a delight I just needed i eivol
spasiba bomb how do you know Russian by
the way my grandparents were Russian
shut the front door yeah they were
Russian Jews like they like the born and
Russian they immigrated my great
grandparents best in Charlotte emigrated
from Russia and so your grandparents
spoke to you in Russian my
great-grandparents said your grandma /
older ones like bunny and harder
supposed to mean something like in
British
and sometimes they don't really speak
Russian but garten Charlotte be Gretchen
to me and then I dated a Russian Jews
for a long time why would you do that
why why don't know my roots I don't know
so you know a little bit a little bit
photo scheme very nice well very very
little yeah I am I am just so honored
and it was just so great to chat with
you great parenting advice um I where
can people find you like are you doing
you're hired com okay whatever on Hey
look fantastic and are you i know you're
not doing set up anymore but are you
recording any songs are you doing for me
yeah i'm performing in February 25th in
New York my award-winning solo show I
have my dad we show that's starting to
tour called the word dangerous into
delicious love it love it which I do
stand-up in by the way but I don't call
it I don't have to yes it's singing and
stand up put together that's a song them
straight you know yeah I guess I don't
do it but I don't do it you know the way
that you do it right right and and I can
I are you doing like youryour jazzy
blues like what are you what's would
start yeah its job you did it with
comedy in between oh that's so great
that's so awesome tell people it's
called again say they say the name again
the board divorce dangerous and
divalicious got it okay beautiful well I
hope it'll absolutely thank you so much
and I hope one day we can connect in
person may be out here in la at another
Kelly Carlin party or maybe I'll see you
out in New York very soon spasiba this
vid Anya and we'll talk soon Oh bye-bye
alright so that was rain and I think
she's going to still continue to do her
show in New York City a show called that
daughter's crazy let's see februari
sixth and seventh it's the Atlanta
Jewish Film Festival all right well
that sounds great go check her out if
you're around but of course you know
like she said she's maybe not doing
stand up anymore but still look for her
performing she's an incredible singer as
well if you've never seen her saying
just Google some YouTube videos she's
she's really great and so spiritual i
love i love that about her i feel like i
have a kid-friendly kin no not that's
not what I'm kindred spirit thank you in
a in crunchiness with her and and follow
her on the on the Twitter and follow us
here at the studio all things comedy is
our twitter handle here and i am at kira
comedy and of course the show is at kira
soltanovich and i don't think i've asked
this of you guys in a while but can you
go to the iTunes and can you go and
leave us a review that would be swell I
keep forgetting keep forgetting to
mention that but if you leave a review
and give us some stars and and some high
fives and some accolades that would be
so appreciated I know that kind of helps
the podcast out right it kind of shoves
us into like a the top five thousand
good that's a good place to be um let's
see where am I gonna be I'm in Omaha
that's Omaha Nebraska January 28 that's
like a gig for like the Warren Buffett
people aight aight about that yeah i
don't know if you can like get tickets
to that or what but it's it's a ladies
night out event Warren Buffett's putting
it on in Omaha if you're around thursday
the twenty eighth of january and and
then i'm around for a little while
I'm in town doing some stuff i'll be
able to give you guys more details very
soon hopefully very exciting news to
share with you soon thanks for listenin
I'll talk to you later
you